[Música]
qué honor a estar aquí hoy con ustedes
para uno de los mejores eventos del
mundo
la verdad es no soy español
hace cinco años no hablaba su idioma
hoy
fuera de mi zona de confort voy a
contarles dos historias de mi vida sobre
la innovación
empezamos con la primera historia
cuando tenía nueve años encontré
el increíble mundo de star wars
este mundo me fascinó
la interacción de humanos de robots
y de criaturas totalmente raros
la curación de lesiones instantánea
los viajes a él
la velocidad de la luz
esta fascinación creó en mí un
interminable hambre de innovación
si te dijera que la ciencia ficción
estará aquí hoy
aprovéchate el cinturón
en este momento cada 3.4 meses
duplica
la velocidad
de las computadoras significa que el
próximo la próxima semana tendremos
computadoras dobles la velocidad que en
enero
unos científicos han desarrollado micro
robots que entran en los vacíos vasos
sanguíneos eso es un salto cuántico en
la detección de enfermedades
y google está creando un mundo de
realidad mixta trayendo información
digital frente a nuestros ojos
hologramas a nuestro alrededor
el mundo 5g
estar aquí hoy
muy pronto computadoras y humanos
estarán conversando
estamos en un punto crítico
el cambio
está acelerando y se está volviendo
imposible de comprender
mi pregunta es sientes miedo
o curiosidad
es la diferencia fundamental para tu
potencial de innovar
esto casi siempre olvidamos en el
desarrollo del liderazgo
pero puede ser el aspecto más importante
sientes miedo o curiosidad cuando
enfrentas a retos nuevos
cuando observamos la reacción humana
al cambio hay dos mentalidades la
mentalidad
efe y la mentalidad
la mentalidad efe viene de la palabra
feel miedo en inglés
las personas en esta mentalidad
enfrentando al cambio de los retos
nuevos por la mayor parte con miedo
la gran mayoría de la gente opera en
esta mentalidad y muchos líderes tienen
miedo crónico de cometer errores así son
buenos modelos de a seguir
los sistemas organizacionales tratan de
controlar el cambio
pero la realidad es controlar el cambio
es como ir a nadar sin mojarse es
imposible
el riesgo es
que la microgestión la burocracia la
necesidad de control mata a la
creatividad
las personas se desconectan
y trabajan según el protocolo
hermosas aves en una jaula las alas
cortadas
hay un estudio de gallup que muestra que
al 85% de los empleados no les gusta su
trabajo 85%
y no es sorpresa cuando miramos a la
ciencia
el ser controlado
crea un flujo de cortisol en nuestra
cabeza que inhibe la liberación
de la oxitocina
de la hormona del amor
esto es uno
la mentalidad efe nos oxida
es como una bicicleta oxidada
y muestra que no hemos tenido cuidado
por qué
la destrucción
la creatividad
y reemplaza al viejo
reemplaza al viejo o como dice mi amigo
florian sin curiosidad morimos
lentamente
por otro lado la mentalidad se tenemos
que cultivar
las personas en esta mentalidad
enfrentan al cambio por la mayor parte
con curiosidad
en términos de bioquímica significa que
una liberación de dopamina
ayuda a los empleados a identificarse
comprometer
lo que nadie nos enseña
es que la innovación opera en la
dimensión de cambio constante
no puedes enseñar trucos nuevos a un
perro viejo
a menos que una persona esté
acostumbrada a adaptarse es difícil que
cambie
lo he visto
por primera persona
y esto me lleva a la segunda historia
cuando era niño casi muero de cáncer
y esto
creo en mí um
una mentalidad de miedo
creo en mi vida varios sistemas para
evitar riesgos y no convirtió convertí
en un fanático de control
un día
volvía del trabajo en bicicleta y
prestando poca atención a la carretera
choque con un obstáculo
y voló por los aires
en el impacto
la única cosa que recuerdo
era que hay algo que se rompía
el accidente partió en dos mitades mi
casco de bicicleta por suerte no era mi
cabeza
justo escape
de la muerte una vez más
y este fue mi llamada de atención
no sabemos qué va a pasar mañana
entonces por qué intentar controlar todo
solo después
de hacer un cambio radical en mi vida
puede verlas hechas de una perspectiva
externa
y me pregunte algo muy sencillo pero muy
importante
qué haría sin el miedo
y mi vida nunca volvió a ser la misma
viaje por el mundo investigando estilos
de liderazgo altamente efectivos como
las que se pueden encontrar en empresas
como swisscom amazon
y disney
la clave es
un negocio es tan bueno
como la mentalidad del liderazgo un
negocio es tan bueno
la mentalidad del liderazgo lo que los
líderes altamente efectivos realmente
hacen es
ayudar a su equipo
a enfrentar
a los retos nuevos a pesar del miedo
líderes altamente efectivos
ofrecen una visión inspiradora
según nos dan libertad a los expertos en
vez de micro gestionarlos
y en el tiempo que año
quitando la microgestión
tan atención a los líderes del futuro
mis modelos a seguir estos señores
richard feynman
el receptor del premio nobel de física
qué habilidad de enseñar
temas muy complejos
a cualquier persona
rusli
el maestro de artes marciales
mira en sus ojos enfrentando
en el resto en el resto nuevo
su mirada y también richard branson el
fundador del grupo virgin que quiten que
tienen todos ellos en común
lo que tienen en común es su actitud
una actitud
mi abuelo
llamó alegremente diligente
como seguiría el mundo
y la mayoría de los líderes hubieran
cultivado
esta mentalidad se de curiosidad
una noche después de viajar a 70 países
reunidos los resultados en un proyecto
llamado crowd masters la visión es la
educación de líderes para el futuro
retiramos los líderes de su zona de
confort y los llevamos a ambientes
totalmente inusuales como brasil como
indonesia
como himalayas al textura del mundo
la meta es
darse cuenta
los hábitos de liderazgo obsoletos
lo hacemos con tres puntos distintos
primero aventura
típica estrés agudo
como en el gimnasio el entrenamiento en
el gimnasio pero para el mente
y el resultado de esto es una mejor toma
de decisiones segundo la co-creación
mostrando nuevas perspectivas desde un
igual igual y no desde una mirada
jerárquica
que se para
la co-creación
y cultiva
humildad vulnerabilidad y
responsabilidad
en mi experiencia la curiosidad
es la habilidad
ale a la que tenemos que apuntar porque
la curiosidad tiene un efecto positivo a
todas las otras habilidades
por supuesto no es una idea muy popular
porque no se puede correlacionar ningún
tapiz o medir el uruguay
pero últimamente solo vale una pregunta
cuál es el costo de la inacción
el primer paso para dejar un mundo mejor
a nuestros hijos es salir de nuestra
zona de confort
y acostumbrarnos al cambio
chicos
cultiven la curiosidad desde el
principio viajen por el mundo
para aprender de varios ángulos y no
tengan miedo
de intentar cosas nuevas
mayores
rey descubran la curiosidad
expongan sea una incomodidad
frecuentemente
por ejemplo pueden
experimental
de alguna manera cada semana
así cuando un cambio fundamental es
necesario
pueden dar el salto a lo desconocido
porque esto siempre ha sido la propia
edad del futuro desconocido gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]